What's up guys welcome back to the King of Random kitchen
you guys have been asking for it
you guys have been waiting for it
so in today's episode I'm finally doing it
I'm teaching you how to make liquid nitrogen
I've been really hesitant to put out a video
on how I make liquid nitrogen
because honestly
my setup isn't very professional
It's all jury-rigged together
realize you guys don't really care what
it looks like you're more interested in
how its functions so that's what we're
getting into today now if you go outside
and take a deep breath you're filling
your lungs with about 20% oxygen 79%
nitrogen and 1% of other gases now the
first step in making liquid nitrogen is
just to take the regular atmosphere and
compress it into some kind of a
container that can hold it under
[ pressure ]
once it's under pressure we can pass it
through a nitrogen membrane which will
separate the oxygen and the other gases
leaving pure nitrogen gas behind but
there's one other problem the nitrogen
might have some moisture associated with
it and we don't want any moisture so the
next step is to pass that gas through
some kind of mechanism that dries it out
now in one of the secret compartments of
my room I have this nitrogen generator
that does all that for me and I really
have to give credit where credit's due
to my friend Chris Roberts who really
made all this possible he's the one that
located all the items he sourced all the
equipment he helped put it all together
and he helped it get to the functioning
state that it is today now once we've
got the clean dry nitrogen gas we need a
place to store it
my friend Chris went down to Harbor
Freight and pick up a little tank for
about 20 bucks that we use to store that
nitrogen gas under pressure and we added
a little regulator so we can turn a knob
and regulate how much gas flows out and
now it might seem a little bit too
simple but that's half the battle in
making liquid nitrogen
once we've got dry nitrogen seeping out
at about 1 psi all we have to do is get
it cold enough that it liquefies and
this is where we bring in the helium
compressor now helium compressor unit is
basically just a glorified air
conditioning unit the whole purpose of
this existence is to get colder than the
boiling point of nitrogen now helium has
a boiling point around minus 452 degrees
Fahrenheit which is way below the
boiling point of liquid nitrogen
I think it's Boyle's law that says if
you take a gas and compress it and then
let it cool back down if you rapidly
expand it that gas will get very very
cold and because we're using helium we
can compress it cool that gas down and
rapidly expand it to a temperature
that's lower than the boiling point of
liquid night
so now that you've got the basic concept
let me explain in a little bit more
detail how a helium compressor works
it's charged up with helium gas in a
closed-loop system the helium gas is
compressed where it keeps up
tremendously and we need some kind of a
system to cool it down which I'll talk
about in just a minute but once it is
cooled down it can travel to the cryo
head where it's rapidly expanded and
cooled down to a temperature lower than
the boiling point of nitrogen so what
would happen if we had a surface that
was colder than the boiling point of
liquid nitrogen and we had a small vapor
of nitrogen gas blowing at it that's
right it's going to condense and is
going to form small droplets and drip
down to ground now if we're able to
catch those droplets into some kind of a
glorified thermos a Dewar if you will
then theoretically over time those
droplets would add up and produce
bucketfuls of liquid nitrogen and that's
it guys that is exactly how we make
liquid nitrogen hey guys just stepping
out here for a minute because this is
real life you know what else is real
life shaving your face this video is
sponsored by Dollar Shave Club
they sent me a box of razors and asked
me to tell you about their services and
hook you up with some sweet promos if
you haven't heard about them by now
Dollar Shave Club sends razor blades
right to your front door and since I
shave every day switching to them is
really the smarter choice and if you're
old enough to have facial hair it could
be the smarter choice for you as well
check out the description right now and
you'll see a link to dollarshaveclub.com
the king of random this will transport
you to a really great offer to where you
can get your first month's package for
only $5 the package has an executive
razor for cartridges and a tube of dr.
Carver shave butter which is a $15 value
you get it for only $5 you don't need to
overspend on fantasy razors to get a
quality shave keep shaving simple with
Dollar Shave Club you get quality razors
delivered right to your door without any
of the hassle they have free shipping no
hidden fees and you can cancel anytime
you like and it only takes around 10
seconds to drop down to the description
to yourself folks out so seriously if
you have a face and you shave it stop
what you're doing and click the link in
the description or go to
dollarshaveclub.com the king of random
I'm hooking you up with great razors at
great prices so you can make the smarter
choice and get your shaving stuff on its
way
you're literally losing money by not
signing up hey don't good stuff
membership club oh you are I love it no
kidding you know be in a video
all right guys time is up back to the
video I'll be back up for a second and
just talk about the cooling system we
used for the Gila
compressor which is pretty cool because
it's just jury-rigged out a
three-component my friend Chris and I
start out by building a housing for the
furnace blower and the radiator so we
could suck in tremendous amounts of air
and blow it through the radiator and
cool down all the liquid inside next we
ran some poly hoses from the radiator
all the way back to the helium
compressor where it runs through a heat
exchanger where it soaks in all the heat
from the compressed helium runs it back
to the radiator and cools down once
again and this whole system is powered
by a sump pump that I got from Home
Depot for about 20 bucks I just built it
so it sits inside of a little bucket
inside of a bigger bucket that way if
any water splashes out it's not going to
damage our electronics now the sump pump
runs on normal house power about 120 AC
but the nitrogen generator and the
helium compressor run on 240 and by now
I know you've probably got two questions
on your mind how much energy does
actually use and how much nitrogen gets
generated cats are the first question I
don't really know how much power it uses
but it's not enough to make a difference
in our monthly electric bill and answer
the second question how long does it
take to make well to make 30 litres
which fills up my Dewar it takes about
three weeks remember guys we not only
have to get the Dewar cold enough where
it can hold liquid nitrogen without
evaporating but then we have to fill it
the rest of the way up by drip by drip
and that takes a really long time so
where do you find all this equipment
well honestly we found it on Amazon eBay
and we found it at university surplus
and as long as you can find a nitrogen
compressor with a nitrogen membrane a
helium compressor a cryo head and Jimmy
rig your own liquid cooling system you
could probably make one of these for
yourself but as my friend nurdrage says
I'm going to have to crush your
expectations because even jury-rigging
it together yourself it's still going to
cost you a lot of money I've got about a
thousand maybe $1,300 and see unit I've
got here so when we draw it out like
this it kind of looks like a complicated
system and there are a lot of moving
parts but what it comes down to our two
main essentials dry nitrogen gas meeting
a very cold surface the nitrogen
condenses gets liquefied and then gets
captured into some kind of a container
that can keep it nice and cold and
that's it that's the basics of making
liquid nitrogen in a nutshell so there
you have a guy's mystery solved you now
know how to make liquid nitrogen by
pulling nitrogen right out of the air
and getting it so cold that it liquefied
hey thanks for joining me for this video
I'll be looking for you the next one
talk to you then liquid nitrogen due to
paper shiny and wet just like a liquid
now our paper is really really cold